today we're going to cancel
the women's ncaa march madness
tournament now i know what you're
thinking
there's a women's march madness
tournament yes i had the exact same
thought when i was made aware of the
sexism controversy surrounding the
women's tournament
and the accommodations that the female
athletes are receiving in comparison to
the men so here's the the usa today
here's usa today with news on the
controversy it says the ncaa
acknowledges
the discrepancy and amenities between
the men's and women's basketball
tournament on thursday after images
posted social media drew significant
backlash picture surfaced thursday
showing the stark differences in gifts
that were presented to women's
basketball players compared to men's
stanford sports performance coach ali
kirschner posted photos of the
facilities inside the indianapolis
bubble
compared to the san antonio bubble wnba
star sabrina
uh iyunsku a big big fan of hers
last year last year's national player of
the year in ncaa women's basketball
fumed over a poor display in the weight
room tweeting
quote women's ncaa bubble weight room
versus men's weight room
thought this was a joke wtf what is this
to all the women playing in the march
madness tournament keep grinding
the picture showed the plentiful options
in the internet in an indianapolis
weight room compared to a small rack of
dumbbells in san antonio
ajo wilson who plays for the las vegas
aces and
the wnba another player that i
am not only aware of but a huge fan of
tweeted
the weight room situation is beyond
disrespectful then sedona price who
plays for oregon
posted a tick tock calling out the
disparity between amenities writing
intercaption it's 20 21 and we are still
fighting for bits and pieces of equality
okay now the end of the uh naac the ncaa
there we go
has apologized and pledged to fix the
problem but to give you the visual
if you're watching the daily wire
youtube right now here is sedona price
with her tick tock video complaining
about this discrepancy
in the way that the men and women are
being treated let's watch
i got something to show y'all so for the
ncaa march madness the biggest
tournament
in college basketball for women this is
our weight room
let me show you all the men's weight
room
now when pictures of our weight room got
released versus the men's the ncaa came
out with a statement saying that it
wasn't money
it was space that was a problem let me
show y'all something else
here's our practice court right and then
here's that weight room
and then here's all this extra space
if you aren't upset about this problem
then you're a part of it well then i
guess i'm a part of it
because i'm not that upset i have to say
it's not on my top 20 list of concerns
in my life right now
is that the women ncaa players
don't have enough weights in the weight
room
see it's one thing if you simply asked
for better equipment
you know that that's fair i won't
begrudge you that i have to admit the
first time i saw that video
uh and i'll admit this myself the first
time i saw that video
and i saw the women's weight room set uh
i did
burst out laughing hysterically i can't
help it don't don't blame me the problem
is that it's just extremely funny
to me but i can understand why the
ladies might want a bit more to work
with than a rack of five pound dumbbells
at least
get some ten pounders on there for god's
sake and and a couple of yoga mats
the problem though is when you lecture
me
that i need to be upset about women
basketball players not having all the
exercise equipment they want
and you tell me that i'm a part of some
greater societal problem and you demand
equality see
that's where the problem comes in and
i'll tell you why that's a problem
there is no equality between men's and
women's sports
especially men's and women's basketball
the equality doesn't exist
any effort to make them equal or to
treat them equally
is absurd here's a simple fact the men's
ncaa
tournament generates billions and
billions of dollars
the women's tournament according to the
wall street journal doesn't turn a
profit
it loses money so you have on one hand a
sport that makes
billions on the other a sport that makes
nothing actually earns negative
it has to be propped up kept afloat put
on artificial life support
men's basketball keeps women's
basketball in existence
the very existence of women's basketball
is a favor
that men's basketball is doing for it
because it can't survive on its own that
again that's just a fact
to give you one isolated example ohio
state the men's program earns over 10
times as much revenue from ticket sales
as the women and that's
only ticket sales 10 times as much
now why is that why does men's
basketball both on the collegiate and
professional level
completely trounce women's basketball
and revenue well because
nobody cares about women's basketball
nobody watches it
nobody goes to the games almost nobody
anyway and what this means is that
the vast majority of the people
pretending to be upset about the unequal
treatment of female athletes
also themselves do not watch the women's
games or have any real interest
in them so they're standing off to the
side basically saying yeah
you know i don't give a damn about this
i think it's boring as hell but uh sure
yeah
it's an outrage if this thing i don't
care about and that nobody else seems to
care about
isn't treated the same as the thing i do
care about that everybody else cares
about
it's absurd see i would have a lot more
respect for sedona here
if she had said listen i know we aren't
as important as the men's side
and i know that the men are keeping us
in business um and i
i really appreciate that by the way
thanks guys for for allowing us to exist
as a team
because we wouldn't if not for you but
we'd still really appreciate some better
accommodations
i'd respect that i'd be on her side but
instead we get lectures and speeches
about equality
and when you come at me like that it's a
non-starter any discussion of equality
is a non-starter men's and women's
sports are not equal
will never be equal it should not be
treated as equal and the thing is you
might be mad you might want to be mad at
me for saying that
but you can't really be mad because
you're not watching it either
so yeah you're part of the problem with
all that said
i support women's sports i want women's
sports to continue to exist
and the greatest existential threat to
the continued existence of women's
sports is not a lack of workout
equipment
it is rather of course the intrusion of
males into those leagues
that's why i'm fighting to keep males
out anyone who is not fighting for that
or is instead
actively fighting to get men into these
sports can't pretend to be upset about
unequal accommodations
when you get your way women's sports
won't exist at all
that's the real threat and it stems from
the same confusion that leads people to
be upset about girl basketball players
not being treated the same as guy
basketball players
the confusion is in the belief that men
and women are the same
interchangeable not different in any
significant or fundamental way
but they are different they are not the
same they're not equal
as equal means same and that's why the
women's basketball tournament
isn't owed the same treatment or the
same accommodations
but it's also why women athletes are
owed the basic protection of keeping men
out of their sports and that's how this
all breaks down
and those who don't understand that are
cancelled
i guess i also said at the top that the
whole women's tournament is canceled
that may be a bit harsh on second
thought you know also kind of redundant
nobody's watching it anyway
and far be it for me to cancel something
that i just learned existed
five seconds ago so instead we'll
we'll keep the cancellation more broadly
that's another favor that i will do
for the ladies you're welcome hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i
demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat
appreciated